subscribe
it's 10 o'clock the purpose of this
hearing
is to consider a review of a premises
license
under section 51 of the licensing act
2003
in respect of the caffeine lounge 14
borehampton gate committee center
certainly licensing co 10
um to it's the first of october 220. my
name is
10 o'clock i am the purpose of legal
hearing
to the subcommittee this morning
before without any ado i can confirm
that prior to
this morning the subcommittee received
an application to a journey's hearing
from the legal representatives
instructed by
the license holder
notice of having received that
request for an adjournment was provided
to all interested parties
and the subcommittee has considered that
application
as it would do with any such application
on its merits the subcommittee has had
to balance on the one hand
to need to deal with the review as
expeditiously as possible
whilst at the same time having regard to
transparency
and the fairness of the review process
the licensing act 2003 hearings
regulations 2005
give the power in certain circumstances
to provide
more time or alternatively adjourn
any review hearing if it believes that
it
considers it to be in the public
interest
having regard to the particular
circumstances of this
particular review hearing the
subcommittee have taken a view
that in these circumstances and for this
one occasion only
they are prepared to exceed to the
application
to adjourn this review hearing
and in the circumstances that they
would ask that the review hearing be
adjourned to
friday the 23rd of october 2020
at 10 am
having made the decision to adjourn to
that date
the subcommittee have asked me to
confirm that
they would wish to make clear that any
submissions
and further supporting evidence which is
to be
lodged for the purposes of that
adjourned
hearing on the 23rd of october should be
provided in a timely fashion
to ensure that the review hearing does
proceed
as planned at 10 am on friday the 23rd
of october
at 2020.
in those circumstances that is the um
confirmation of the decision by the
licensing subcommittee
agreed okay yeah thank you david for
that and i think that's
that's it for everybody thank you all
for turning up this morning
thank you thank you
you